un repas en terrasse une scène typique
du quotidien parisien mais les vins non
inscrits ici sont un rappel qu'il ya
près de six ans ce lieu de vie a été
transformé à jamais l'équipe c'est ma
maison il ya vingt personnes qui sont
mortes dans la maison certaines se
faisait partie de ma vie et d'autres
faisait partie beaucoup beaucoup noisy
grégory reibenberg est propriétaire de
plusieurs restaurants dont la belle
équipe l'une des terrasses attaqué par
les terroristes le 13 novembre 2015 s'il
a perdu des collègues des amis et la
mère de sa fille c'est pour eux qu'il
témoignera dans le cadre du procès
consacrée aux atteintes à sait très bien
que la réparation passe beaucoup par la
parole donc quand on est dans un pays où
cela est possible il faut le faire c'est
indispensable moi ça ne l'est pas
personnellement pour moi mais il n'y a
pas que moi il ya vingt personnes qui
sont dans mon établissement c'est
important d'y participer et aussi parce
que ce soutien indéfectible de ma fille
sa maman est assassiné et elle pourrait
à défaut nous reprocher déçu de ne pas
pouvoir
porter sa parole ce procès l'un des plus
importants de l'histoire moderne la
france est aussi celui de l'attentât du
bataclan l'attak de deux heures dans la
salle de spectacle a fait 90 morts et
des centaines de blessés des souvenirs
douloureux que ce procès risque de
raviver on réfléchit à plein de trucs
après si si j'avais pas été fatiguée si
j'avais pas suivi mon ami j'aurais été
là est-ce que autour de mâle compte ce
théâtre le 13 novembre se firent un jeu
avait réussi à s'échapper c'est quand
même très important d'avoir un procès
parce que c'est quelque chose qui doit
être voilà
officialisé parce que c'est vrai que
pour l'instant ça reste quelque chose
qui nous est arrivé il n'y a rien eu
derrière on est seul face à cet
événement mais oui en contrepartie c'est
c'est une résurgence des images et d'une
époque qu'on aimerait enterré donc
ces deux choses qu'il va falloir gérer
au coeur de paris au sein même du vieux
palais de justice une salle a été
construite spécialement pour ce procès
historique qui sera filmé et archiver
ses lacs pendant cinq semaines des
centaines de survivants et de gens qui
ont perdu des proches pourront
s'exprimer
ce fille elle a préféré la plume pour
revivre ces émotions raconté dans un
livre elle a choisi de ne pas témoigner
ça m'a permis de poser des mots des
choses
je ressens pas le besoin maintenant
d'aller d'aller en dire plus devant
devant une audience c'est quelque chose
déjà qui m'intimide la salle est très
intimidante l'idée ne retrouvais avec
cette audience me fait peur il faut une
préparation à la fois psychologiques
technique soit organisé pour que les
meilleures réponses soit importé depuis
des mois des associations de victimes
comme 13 ans 15 multiplie les séances de
préparation et d'accompagnement pour
philippe dupeyron le moment est
important son fils thomas est mort au
bataclan nous parlerons de ce que nous
avons perdu cela ne sont plus là pour
pouvoir porter leurs témoignages le
livre ne se refermera jamais mais ce
chapitre là est important et une lille
se refermera pour grégory reibenberg la
reconstruction personnelle et
professionnelle est entamée depuis des
années il ne s'attend pas à ce que le
procès répondent à toutes les questions
mais pour le pays ces audiences ont
toute leur pertinence c'est une
intemporalité cet événement là c'était
hier matin c'était il ya deux sont
mineurs est ce vraiment arrivé je le vis
comme ça je sais que c'est pas le seul à
vivre comme ça donc je n'en attends rien
sur ce que j'attends c'est que ça
n'affecte pas trop ma fille est aussi
que justice soit rendue
ici raphaël bouvier auclair radio-canada
paris